endlich wir haben lange darauf warten
müssen aber es ist wieder ein neues
teilchen entdeckt wurden und wie beim
higgs boson wurde es vorhergesagt vor
knapp 50 jahren und nun konnte es
endlich aufgespürt werden und das fast
zeitgleich in zwei verschiedenen
experimenten die rede ist von
sogenannten quasi teilchen die
kurzlebige nordens bestehen aus klonen
die wiederum als vermittler teilchen der
starken kernkraft gelten
nun ist also endlich der lang ersehnte
nachweis dieser exotischen teilchen
gelungen und das ist für die physik eine
wahre sensation pixum science im future
geht es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
wow das sind diese gänsehautmomente der
wissenschaft es gibt ein neu entdecktes
teilchen der name order von
physikerinnen und physiker am cern und
am fermilab in den usa ist es fast
zeitgleich gelungen diese neuen teilchen
in ihrem beschleuniger nachzuweisen die
order rons bestehen aus klonen den
vermittler teilchen der starken
kernkraft bereits vor knapp 50 jahren
1973 wurde die existenz dieser ordens
vorhergesagt doch erst jetzt konnten die
neuen teilchen aufgespürt werden
und das fast zeitgleich in zwei
verschiedenen experimenten eine
sensation für die physik denn die neuen
erkenntnisse liefern sensationelle
einblicke in die sogenannte quanten
promo dynamik und diese gilt als
fundamentale theorie der starken
kernkraft und somit sollte man mit ihr
nicht nur in die anfänge des kosmos
zurückblicken können sondern mit ihrer
hilfe auch alle phänomene der kernphysik
vorhersagen können doch dazu müssten die
genauen wechselwirkung zwischen protonen
und neutronen und den jeweiligen
atomkern noch detaillierter beschrieben
werden ist die fachwelt mit den neuen
erkenntnissen diesem ziel ein stückchen
näher gekommen
die ordens gelten als sogenannte quasi
teilchen der fachwelt werden sie damit
von anderen echten partikeln wie quarks
protonen oder elektronen unterschieden
quasi teilchen bestehen aus ansammlungen
kleinere teilchen die sich allerdings
für einen gewissen zeitraum gleich
verhalten sie besitzen beispielsweise
für kurze zeit die gleiche wellenlänge
in der
oder masse oder sonst entstehen wenn
proton kollidieren und dabei eine
ungerade anzahl von clown untereinander
austauschen bei solch einer kollision
werden die protonen selbst also nicht
völlig zerstört es kommt zur
wechselwirkung und die führen dazu dass
die clown zwischen den protonen
ausgetauscht werden dazu sagt der
us-physiker thema crm
die protonen interagieren wie zwei
autotransporter bei einem unfall auf der
autobahn wenn diese lastwagen
kollidieren bleiben sie selbst stark
beschädigt erhalten die auf ihm
befestigten autos aber werden
weggeschleudert die weg geschleuderten
autos stehen in dieser metapher für die
clown die ausgetauscht werden doch das
problem bislang in den experimenten der
vergangenheit konnten bei kollisionen
von protonen immer nur eine gerade
anzahl von blumen beobachtet werden die
leistung der teilchenbeschleuniger gab
bislang einfach nicht mehr her
doch dass es auch anders gehen muss
dachten sich fachleute bereits vor fast
50 jahren und postulierten also sagten
voraus bereits damals die these dass es
auch einen austausch mit einer ungeraden
menge an lohn geben muss genau deswegen
auch ihr name anderen ort ist englisch
und bedeutet um gerade diese teilchen
verhalten sich zusammen genauso wie ein
teilchen erst der experimentelle
indizien auf die existenz der ordens gab
es vor drei jahren und zwar mit hilfe
des toten detektors der am
beschleunigerring des large hadron
collider am cern installiert ist in den
meisten experimenten führen die
kollision der protonen dazu dass diese
zerstört werden doch der tod dem
detektor ist bestens dafür geeignet
diejenigen protonen abzufangen die die
kollisionen überstehen das problem auch
der tod dem detektor ist nicht in der
lage die orange direkt nachzuweisen
die fachleute waren hier auf
auffälligkeiten im strahl verhalten
angewiesen denn diese gelten als
hinweise auf die existenz der ordens und
so wurden bereits 2018 indizien dafür
aufgespürt das bei experimenten ein
austausch einer ungeraden menge von
lohan stattgefunden haben könnte dazu
hieß es damals von einem der beteiligten
physiker christopher j
wir haben messwerte die mit dem
traditionellen modell der geraden lohn
zahlen nicht kompatibel sind wir haben
damit vielleicht zum ersten mal den
austausch einer
ungeraden zahl von lhon beobachtet die
tote im resultate passen zu den
theoretischen modellen eines austauschs
von drei farblosen lohnen in gebundenen
zustand
konkret ging es hier um den sogenannten
roh parameter damit meinen die fachleute
einen wert der das verhältnis
verschiedener signaturen bei kollisionen
mit unterschiedlich hohen energien
ergibt doch klar ist auch dass bei dem
damaligen experiment am cern die daten
lagern nicht so eindeutig war in der
fachsprache ist von der sogenannten
signifikanz die rede
das cern forschungsteam konnte damals
beispielsweise nicht genau sagen ob es
nicht sogar ein austausch von fünf
sieben oder mehr lohnen stattgefunden
hat doch jetzt der erfolg am cern auch
hier nutzten die fachleute wieder die
spezielle apparatur um die order uns ein
für allemal dingfest zu machen
so analysierten die forschenden weitere
daten um auch die protonen kollisionen
mit höheren energien zu sammeln und
auszuwerten
in den experimenten waren die energien
von bis zu 13 tera elektronenvolt am
start das spannende ergebnis wurde
anfang märz während eines treffens am
cern vorgestellt kurios fast zeitgleich
konnte auch ein forschungsteam am us
fermilab also dem forschungszentrum für
teilchenphysik die spektakuläre
entdeckung verkünden
auch die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler dort hatten messungen in
diesem zusammenhang durchgeführt konkret
wurden hier protonen und antiprotonen
aufeinander geschossen und so zur
kollision gebracht theoretisch sollten
dann auch hier nicht nur gradzahl igge
sondern eben auch ungerade zahl liege
die hohen bälle entstehen beide
forschungsteams haben ihre ergebnisse
nun gemeinsam veröffentlicht und das
paper macht klar die existenz von otto
ron scheint nun endgültig bewiesen zu
sein
in den usa konnten die fachleute den
austausch von ungeraden klonen bällen
bei 1,96 tera-elektronenvolt nachweisen
eine deutlich niedrigere energie im
vergleich zum cern experiment mit hilfe
des toten detektors hier konnte die
existenz von ordens bei proton
kollisionen mit 13 tera elektronenvolt
nachgewiesen werden die signifikanz
dafür lag bei 4,6 standardabweichungen
sigma zum verständnis in der
teilchenphysik gilt eine signifikanz von
fünf als entdeckung und das verlangt
eine wahrscheinlichkeit von 99 999
die signifikanz für den nachweis der
ordens bei den beiden experimenten liegt
bei 5,7 sieht man gemeinsam kam es also
zu der sensationellen entdeckung denn
die schwelle ab der ein teilchen fund
offiziell als entdeckung gilt ist somit
überschritten der forscher christoph
rath ist wie alle seine kolleginnen und
kollegen überglücklich dies ist damit
der erste experimentelle nachweis eines
ordens das ist eine große entdeckung für
das cern und das fermilab denn fest
steht der nachweis der ordens liefert
spannende einblicke in die
wechselwirkung auf sub atomarer ebene
zudem liefern die neuen erkenntnisse
bestätigung für grundlegende vorhersagen
der quanten kromer dynamik qcd diese
theorie beschreibt wie die bausteine von
atomen miteinander in wechselwirkung
treten sie beschreibt also auch wieso
der atomkern der aus elektrisch
neutralen neutronen und positiv
geladenen protonen besteht
zusammengehalten wird dieser theorie
zufolge gibt es eben neben den quartz
eine zweite teilchen a die union also
die austausch teilchen die die starke
kernkraft zwischen den materieteilchen
vermitteln sowohl quarks als auch clown
werden in der qcd durch quanten felder
beschrieben die sich zu jedem zeitpunkt
im gesamten raum ausbreiten um das ganze
zu vereinfachen wird der kontinuierliche
raum und die kontinuierliche zeit durch
ein gitter ersetzt so kommt es dass die
kanten felder der blumen und quax eben
nicht mehr in der gesamten raum zeit
existieren sondern nur noch an den
guitar punkten und den entsprechenden
verbindungslinien mit hilfe dieser
gitter quanten pro modell namik konnten
bereits spannende rätsel gelöst werden
beispielsweise konnte so die masse des
protons und anderer teilchen die sich
aufs quax zusammensetzen herausgefunden
werden auch ein rückblick ins frühe
universum wird so möglich denn nach dem
urknall war es extrem heiß im welt hat
alle bindungen schmolzen quasi auf und
so kommt ein freilos und quax existieren
dann kühlt es ab und aus den freien
quarks und gluonen formten sich die
ersten neutronen und protonen mit hilfe
von gitta rechnung konnten fachleute
diesen prozess simulieren so fand man
heraus welcher druck welcher energie und
welche temperaturen damals herrschen
doch eigentlich sollte die kurze dennoch
weit aus dem
wir können denn sie gilt als die
fundamentale theorie der starken
kernkraft eine kraft die dafür sorgt
dass der atom kern bestehend aus positiv
geladenen protonen und neutralen
neutronen zusammengehalten wird diese
kraft muss so stark sein und zwar viel
stärker als die elektrische abstoßung
zwischen zwei positiv geladenen protonen
im atomkern und somit sollte man mit
hilfe der cd tatsächlich alle phänomene
der kernphysik vorhersagen können doch
dazu müssen die genauen wechselwirkung
zwischen protonen und neutronen und den
jeweiligen atomkern noch detaillierter
beschrieben werden mit dem nachweis der
autor uns ist die fachwelt diesem ziel
ein stückchen näher gekommen dazu sagt
die toten sprecherin simone gianni vom
cern der aktuelle nachweis der ordens
belegt nun dass diese kombination auch
ungerade klonen zahlen haben können wie
1973 vorhergesagt dieses ergebnis
ergründet fundamentale eigenschaften der
theorie der kanten chrome oder namik vor
allem das clown mit sich selbst
wechselwirken können es ist wirklich
verrückt wie wenig wir über die teilchen
noch wissen wenn es überhaupt teilchen
sind oder eher phänomene die durch
felder wie das higgs feld dass die masse
verursacht hervorgerufen werden absolut
faszinierend wie auch dieses thema so
dieses hier neue physik durch schickst
teilchen anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren und zwar diesen kanal pixum
science and future bis dann bleibt dran